foreign
[Music]
hello and good morning on a saturday
morning i am super glad that you guys
have joined me here today i cannot
believe how many of you have showed up
already to watch this about bleach
it's one of the questions that i get
asked the most and i'm super excited
that we get to have this conversation
here today now one of the things that
i'm most famous for is giving you tips
and techniques and today i'm going to
give you the tools and hopefully i can
go through every single one of the tools
that we have that are linked below so
that i can explain to you why we use
them and then how
to use them properly and then answer any
of the questions that you guys have
so before we get started i'm going to
play a pre-recorded uh snippet and this
snippet is going to show you how we use
bleed it's going to answer a lot of
questions up front it's also going to
probably spark some questions for you
and so my goal for you is that we get
all of your questions answered in the
short time that we have here today i
really respect your time and especially
that you showed up on a saturday morning
so i'm honored i'm i'm delighted to get
to spend this time with you and so uh we
will jump over and we will watch that
pre-recorded clip now and then i will
jump back in and we will answer your
questions and we'll rock and roll
through this whole thing so uh here we
go
don't do it very often but when you do
you want to make sure you have all the
personal protective equipment that you
need and you have a proper system in
place
and that once it's clean we're going to
maintain it with just regular everyday
cleaning chemicals and we don't need
really strong cleaning chemicals most of
the time but if you do have a shower
like the one we're going to clean today
we do need bleach and here is the
process
the first thing we're going to do is
start with personal protective equipment
i've got a bib apron on that covers all
of my clothing to protect it from any
spray we're going to be using a spray
bottle from any spray getting on my
clothing and then also my shoes so as
part of our personal protective
equipment we are going to wear shoe
covers now we never wear shoe covers in
the shower except
when we're using bleach and that way it
keeps it from getting on our shoes we're
also going to wear a pair of gloves the
gloves are going to keep any spray from
getting on our hands and we are going to
wear a face mask to protect us from
breathing in any fumes now quick tip
once you are ready to spray you're going
to hold your breath while you're
spraying when you have to take a breath
dip out of the shower take room
temperature breathing because it's an
enclosed space and if you breathe in the
fumes it will make your eyes red and it
will be hard on your breathing okay so
we are still gonna wear a face mask but
we're gonna breathe outside the shower
when we spray we're going to hold our
breath inside the shower okay all right
next thing is i have personal protective
glasses that i'm going to wear this will
keep any spray from getting inside my
eyes all right so now that we are
personally protected for climbing inside
our shower before we do we're going to
remove the bath mat if in the event we
end up spraying anything on the floor
and then we step out onto the bath mat
it's going to ruin that bath mat so we
want to make sure we remove the bath mat
before we climb inside the shower now
once the bath mat is removed
i have two terry cloths and these terry
cloths are folded in half i'm just gonna
lay one down right where i'm gonna step
out so my foot will step on one of these
on each side as i climb outside the
shower okay and i will have my shoe
covers on but anything that touched the
shoe covers i don't want to transfer
that onto the floor and i don't want to
transfer it onto the customer's carpet
or anywhere else in their house so as i
step out of the shower if i have bleach
on my feet i'm going to step on a terry
cloth the shoe covers are going to come
off i'm going to wipe off the bottoms of
my shoes then we're going to be good to
go all right the next thing i have is a
great big old bath towel and you say
what is the bath towel for well we're
going to use ozone for this project and
this is an ozone generator right here
the ozone has three oxygen atoms that
are connected to it so it's a molecule
of a light blue gas and ozone is also
known as smog and so what's going to
happen with this ozone generator is once
we spray the bathroom down we're going
to have a lot of fumes inside the
bathroom so we're going to let ozone go
into the air and create a pocket of
ozone around my bathroom and then it's
going to decompose all of the bleach
smell and then once all the fumes and
all the smells are gone then we're gonna
go back in and we're gonna clean the
bathroom okay so we're gonna spray it
first we're gonna leave for about an
hour and a half that's where this bath
towel comes in so what i'm going to do
in order to keep ozone and
bleach fumes from circulating throughout
the house we're going to turn off the
air conditioning and we're going to turn
off the heat and we're going to turn off
the ventilation so we're just going to
create a packet of
ozone and bleach inside the bathroom all
right here's where the bath mat comes in
i don't want any person
plant or pet inside my ozone chamber so
i'm going to take my bath towel and i'm
going to open it up and i'm going to
roll it sideways and i'm going to plant
it below the bottom of the door and that
way when i close the bathroom doors and
it's on the bottom of the door no ozone
can escape and i'm going to turn the
ozone machine on this is perfect for a
master bath it has a timer on it and i'm
going to set the timer for 30 minutes so
30 minutes of ozone then once the ozone
dies down i'm going to let it set for
about an hour and that way all the ozone
can disintegrate out of the air okay now
for the bleach part we're going to climb
inside the shower we're going to spray
the bleach and this is just an empty
bottle i've just got regular straight
bleach the regular straight bleach goes
inside the bottle we're not diluting it
we're going to use it full strength okay
the full strength is what's gonna make
your eyes turn red if for any reason you
don't wear the glasses and you're inside
reading the fumes okay so this is the
reason that we're gonna do such personal
protective equipment and then also our
spray all right so once we have the
spray we're gonna spray the shower from
top to bottom and we're gonna let it
just set we're not gonna agitate it
we're not gonna scrub it we're not gonna
anything we're just going to spray the
entire shower down okay there's a catch
the only part of the shower that we're
not going to spray is all of the
hardware that's the faucet that's the
faucet head and it's the rim around the
glass because we don't want our bleach
to eat all that up okay so no hardware
and no chrome or no bronze or anything
gets sprayed with the bleach we're going
to come in after we're done and we're
going to use a steamer for that now in
chemical safety we know that we can't
mix anything at all with bleach so we're
not going to come in with another
cleaner after we're done we're going to
come in we're going to hose the whole
shower down and we're going to be done
with all the bleach once we're done with
the bleach we're going to come in with a
steamer this is just water okay tap
water we're going to use on the shower
itself now in order to clean the glass
because we have not sprayed the glass
with bleach what we're going to do is
just use a steamer pad and we're going
to use steam and we're going to clean
the walls with the steamer pad then
we're going to clean the grout with the
steamer and you'll notice on the steamer
there's a little tiny head it's very
skinny that will fit with the grout and
so with the grout we're just going to go
up and down very lightly very easily
with the steam and then we're going to
go ahead and steam the rest of the walls
down we're going to squeegee the wall
down we're going to scrape all the water
towards the center of the floor and
we're going to be done with our shower
so instead of it taking us hours to do
we're going to do this setup which is
going to take a couple of minutes then
we're going to let the chemicals and the
bleach do all its work
then we're going to go clean the rest of
the house when we come back everything
will be nice and tidy but
we'll wash everything down and then
we'll just do the steamer quick quick
steam up job and then we're going to be
done with the project and then we can go
ahead and clean the regular bathroom
it's just a regular bathroom so we still
have the bathroom to do but here's the
secret when you go to a customer's house
if you're a professional house cleaner
you're going to do this process at the
very first of the job that way you can
be cleaning the rest of the house then
when you come back the bleach and the
ozone will have already done its job and
then you can go ahead and clean the
bathroom just as you would normally
clean a bathroom and the whole bathroom
is not a deep clean project
all right so i hope that set the stage
and we did get some excellent questions
that came in so thank you so much for
your participation this one is from
laura and she said so straight bleach
will just clean my soap scum
let's be very clear about what bleach is
bleach and this is the one that i'm
referring to today and there are
different brands of bleach and stuff on
the market but this is the one that
we're going to reference today
bleach is not a cleaner bleach is a
disinfectant and so we're going to treat
the bathroom after we do the bleach so
the bleach is going to be like the first
step and the reason we're going to do
this is because if you are a house
cleaner and i don't know are you guys
house cleaners are you guys homeowners
if you're a professional house cleaner
type house cleaner in the comments if
you are an airbnb host and you sanitize
between guests type airbnb host in the
comments and if you are a homeowner type
the word homeowner and then i will kind
of know who's here and then we can guide
our comments toward that but if you are
a professional house cleaner and you
show up at a customer's house and you're
doing a walk through
when you get to the customer's house and
you walk in the bathroom and you see
like a really icky bathtub and it has
the soap scum and it has the build up or
maybe the tub has backed up and there's
like all this gunk in the tub the first
question we want to ask is how did it
get that way and so once we determine
how did it get that way it will help us
determine what the gunk actually is so
if it's soap scum that that we're
probably going to use a degreaser for
right because the soap scum is what
comes from body proteins and it comes
off our bodies it is um the gunk the
dirt the the germs that we have that
we've washed down the drain it's other
soap products
that we've used either shampoo or
conditioner or things like that that
have mixed with water and they either
set on the side of the walls or they
splashed on the sides of the walls and
then they got stuck because they weren't
rinsed off properly so once we know what
we're looking at that's going to help us
determine how exactly we clean it now if
you go into a customer's home
and the tub is backed up and i say the
tub is backed up you usually see a ring
around the tub and what that suggests is
that there's hair clogged in the drain
and so as the water was trying to go
down the drain it did not drain properly
therefore it backed up and it created
that soap scum where there's body
proteins and dirt and grime and shampoo
and stuff like that that has settled in
the tub and then it slowly drained and
as it drained it didn't have a chance to
rinse off the sides of the tub or the
shower therefore it's stuck in the
bottom so if that's what we have we may
have to use a de-clogger which also has
a really potent smell so if you are in a
shower for example and the one that we
just looked at had some of that serratia
marcescens which we call pink slime and
that is very toxic to our bodies and we
don't want that in our showers at all
and that's where the bleach comes in so
once you're aware of what it is you
might just determine that you are going
to use bleach now we do not use bleach
very often i want to make very very
clear that bleach is a specialty product
it's used for special cleaning
situations okay and i have
links below so that you can see what i'm
talking about but i really want us to be
aware this is a specialty product and
should be treated with the utmost
respect and we can't we can't get mad at
bleach for what it does because it's
it's very strong and it's very
designed for a very specific use
i want to stop for a second and say that
for every chemical that exists on the
market there's what's called a safety
data sheet and that is designed by the
globally harmonized system and it's now
man mandated it's it's worldwide that
every chemical must
be provided by the manufacturer a sheet
there are 16 sections on the sheet and
the very first section will tell you the
manufacturer and their phone number and
if you have any questions about the
product whatsoever you can call the
manufacturer and there's like a chemical
safety person that will answer the phone
and they will answer your questions so
that's always really good to know the
second thing that's really important to
know is if there are any hazards
associated with the product it will also
tell you that as well and that's in
section number two of the sixteen
sections if you go to section number
nine it will tell you where on the ph
scale the product lies now seven is
right in the middle and that's neutral
zero is all the way over to the side and
those are going to be your acids all the
way over to your side on 14 that's going
to be your alkalines so we have acids
neutral and then alkalines and so every
number you go from seven in any
direction it's going to be ten times
stronger than the number before so
number eight is ten times stronger than
number seven number nine is ten times
stronger than number eight right all the
way down bleach this particular bottle
of bleach is 12.5
on the ph scale so that is really really
really strong we're not talking about
just a couple numbers away from seven
we're talking about a couple of thousand
numbers away from seven right it's very
strong on the logarithmic scale all
right so that said how do we use bleach
when do we use it
why do we use it i know it gets really
kind of like
should we use it at all it does have a
purpose and so if you know how to use it
you're not going to be scared when you
do use it so a couple things that i want
to talk about while we're still talking
about bleach is bleach first and
foremost i don't know if you ever
noticed this or not but it comes in a
jar that you cannot see through and this
is to protect it from sunlight so that
it stays stable so even if you pour it
into another container it must also be
a non-see-through container just like
hydrogen peroxide for example comes in
that brown container that's a plastic
container that you cannot see through
it's to prevent sunlight from coming
through so all bleach containers will
come in this really durable thick
plastic it's not a regular plastic
container this is a heavy-duty durable
plastic that it won't eat through and
that also the sun can't see through did
you know that that's a fun fact right
how cool is that okay so the next thing
that's really interesting about bleach
is most of the time depending on the
size of the jug and really really every
bleach container that i've that i've
purchased has this wide lid that is
typical of gallon jugs so if you are
using this for regular cleaning and we
saw a lot of people using this for
regular cleaning during the pandemic and
i don't mean to clean things but to
sanitize and disinfect after they've
cleaned things so it's a two-step
process but what they did then is they
were asking lots of questions on how do
i measure the bleach right how do i how
do i know that i got the right amount of
bleach so that's a really great question
so in our um in the links here let me
see if i can find this there is a
um there's uh
and let me remove this here
uh
where's that question
i've got homeowners here i've got house
cleaners hey nick hey anna this is so
exciting if you guys will type in q
before your question then i will know if
you're just saying hi to me and those of
you that have questions because i do
want to come back and i want to answer
all your questions we've got house
cleaners in the room we've got airbnb
hosts we have lots of homeowners this is
so awesome so i'm super excited all
right so this is a pump spray that we
use in professional house cleaning and
the cool part about this is is this
little adapter right here holds one
ounce of clorox or one ounce of cleaning
solution so if we buy any of our
concentrates or we buy a gallon
container which is what we have here you
can just remove this lid and you can put
this in here and one pump will be one
ounce and so if we have a 32 ounce
container let's say that we were going
to use this this is the one that we used
in the demo this is 32 ounces so three
pumps would be one part to 10
ounces of water and so that's how we
would do it for a 32 ounce container we
would do three pumps and that's for
regular sanitizing disinfecting spray so
if you were going to use it to disinfect
like we did during the pandemic you
would use three pumps to a 32 ounce
container and so this is very helpful
for measuring but the thing that i like
best about this is it's scalable and so
if we have employees for example that we
have sent out to do their own measuring
of cleaning chemicals we don't want them
to use it straight if they're going to
use it as a disinfecting spray for flat
surfaces for example right so we want to
make sure that it's measured properly so
that's the reason why i included this
here also these are kind of hard to find
and so
i i'm really keen on having these and so
i just wanted to recommend these to you
if you have a jug and you'll notice that
this one where the lid goes it's a
little bit longer than the jug itself
because this is plastic you can just cut
that off so that it matches the size of
your jug and still reaches to the bottom
so there's a helpful tip right there all
right so the next thing about the bleach
when we're using the bleach um if we're
using it to clean out a shower like the
one that i mentioned when you get to a
customer's house the very first thing
that we're going to do like let's say
that this is the first time that you've
cleaned the house and if you don't use
bleach and you don't have a system
you're probably going to end up spending
a lot of time and energy
going through the house making sure that
you are cleaning the house doing a
regular maintenance or deep clean and
then you're going to end up spending a
lot of time maybe an hour or so trying
to clean those icky showers so the very
first thing that you want to do is you
want to budget your time properly
because time is money right so the first
thing we're going to do is we're going
to treat with bleach then we're going to
get out of the room and then we're going
to go clean the rest of the house while
the bleach is doing its job and so the
first thing that we're going to do is we
are going to use straight bleach if you
have a really icky shower now what we're
looking for in the shower is we're
looking for mold and we're looking for
that pink slime and so if there's
anything that's stuck on the bottom
that's just like really nasty and you're
like oh no it's going to take me an hour
to clean the shower and you'll start
recognizing after a minute like it's one
of those showers okay the first thing
that we're going to do is we're going to
go to the sink in the bathroom
to the sink in the bathroom and over the
sink we're going to pour the
clorox or pour the bleach into a spray
bottle that we can use and i do have and
i do recommend a funnel
the funnel the purpose of the funnel
is that we will
not spill it on the customers
countertops or um i don't know
on ourselves or any of those things this
is a regular funnel and i just cut the
end off so that it flows quicker through
the jar instead of it comes down to a
little tiny point and it then takes
forever to to put it inside but when
we're done with this you remember how i
said we can't
leave it inside the container we're not
even going to take it out of the
bathroom inside this container so what
we're going to do is we're going to take
this to the customer's house just like
this it's got a lock lid on it so it's
not going to spill in our car it's not
going to spill on the cleaning caddy and
i think this is the only product that we
actually carry in its original container
to the customer's house all the other
chemicals can be mixed in our inventory
and we just take a bottle of spray or
whatever so many things have happened
and i don't want to run the risk of the
lid coming off or this leaking in your
caddy or getting dumped over or anything
and i will stop for a second and say
these are phenomenal spray bottles and
they've got the lock lid where you just
unscrew it and it can go from spray to
stream depending on what you need so i
really like the container but for we
don't want to leave it inside the bottle
for a couple of reasons
if we leave it inside the bottle around
the edge where we have sprayed it's
going to crystallize and it's going to
crystallize on the inside where it gets
sucked up the hose and into the sprayer
just because of the nature of what
bleach is so then when you go to spray
it next time you're going to do the pump
thing 20 times and nothing's going to
come out not only that but because
sunlight has gotten through your bottle
if you leave the inside the bottle it
will have oxidized some and it will not
be effective and then you'll be using
your bleach and you'll be going like
well just use it the other day how come
it's not working that's why it's not
working and so you want to make sure
that when you are done spraying that you
pour it back inside the bottle now the
exception is you can wait until it does
its job when you come back in the
bathroom because we're gonna leave the
bathroom while it does its job you can
just leave it inside here for a minute
when you come back then you will pour it
in before you go to the next step of
cleaning so these are our tools for that
icky icky icky bathtub okay i'm glad we
got that taken care of okay now um
another thing that i want to mention
while i'm on the bottles before i move
on and i should mention this
um
if you're using a bottle like this
nobody except you knows what's inside
and i really want to stop for a second
say that responsible cleaning means that
you need to label all of your containers
and because we're going to be the only
one in the bathroom and we're going to
be the only one pouring this in here
it's okay if we don't label it for this
one job before we leave the bathroom
we're going to empty this out back into
the original container and we're only
using straight bleach so it's not
diluted with anything okay but for your
other bottles and this is a note for
your other bottles for your other
bottles we need to have a label
and this needs to be in your care
custody and control a hundred percent of
the time if someone else takes the lid
off and they dump this out and they pour
something else in whatever is inside the
bottle that you use whether you're a
homeowner or an airbnb host or
professional house cleaner whatever is
in your hand if you sprayed it it's
inside your care custody and control and
if you sprayed something and somebody
switched out the chemicals on you
the insurance company will not cover it
if there's property damage and that's
because you are in control of your
chemicals so i cannot stress the
importance enough of you gotta know
what's inside your bottles i love these
bottles because we do use lots of
concentrates as professionals and so as
professionals this is uh this is a
bathroom product that we use but i have
a label here and we use a lot of the
odoband products and otoban is
phenomenal where they provide the labels
for you on their website you just
download them print them and then put
packing tape over it and tape them on
your containers and you'll notice that
here if you look up closely this is the
dilution ratio so if i have a 16 ounce
container i have one of these pump
sprays
and if i'm doing a heavy duty cleaning
check it out this is where it gets
exciting then i would check this box
which is i have it i have it here for
for the 32. so is it 1 ounce for 16 or
is it 1 ounce for 32.
so you have a choice and so by doing
that this is the heavy duty version
because it's only this would be two
pumps for 32 ounce right and then one
for 32 would be for your maintenance
clean so you can use the same chemical
for maintenance or deep clean all right
that leads me to my next
topic when we're cleaning a bathroom
with bleach that's going to be
considered a deep clean or a special
product a special project that is not a
maintenance clean okay on a maintenance
clean we do not bring the bleach into
people's houses that's a special product
it's a special job it's a special
everything and you need special personal
protective equipment when you use it and
so we are not going to bring bleach with
us on a regular maintenance clean got it
okay cool all right now that said
for maintenance cleaning we'll talk
about that after i answer some of your
questions um and we do have some
questions here which i'm super excited
to answer thank you guys so much
um
smokey of stormwind says i would
recommend using some sort of a mask n95
a respirator and safety glasses if you
plan to use a spray bottle for bleach
also clean the spray bottle with soap
and water to stop the pump from getting
blocked yes all of those apply all of
those apply now if for any reason you
decide that you don't have uh
respirators and you're not using the n95
you can use a regular mask this is not
gonna protect you from fumes okay what
we're gonna do is this if you go inside
a bathroom this is on a deep clean
you're going to go in a bathroom and you
have one shower one icky shower spraying
it down is going to take you about 60
seconds that's it 60 seconds so what
we're going to do is we're going to put
the mask on and the mask is for us the
mask is to remind us
that we are inside a shower and while we
have it on we are not going to breathe
you're going to dump yourself inside the
shower you're going to grab your spray
you're going to hold your breath and
you're going to spray the shower down
you're going to step out of the shower
you're going to turn your head and take
a breath but you're not going to be
breathing the fumes inside the sharks
that's a really tight tiny closed space
right then you're going to get out of
the bathroom so for 60 seconds most
house cleaners and the reason that i say
this is most house cleaners will not
carry big respirator masks with the big
you know we're not we're not going to be
spending all day in there we're going to
spend less than 60 seconds spraying the
walls down and then we're going to bolt
okay so it's going to be quick in quick
out and we're done all right um and i
love this question because we do have to
think about safety protective equipment
one of the things that uh uh and anne
says odoban what is your experience with
this cleaner it smells nice and it says
disinfect but being a bleach fan i'm
doubtful um okay so
it does do a phenomenal job for
disinfecting and i think odoban is one
of the few products on the market that
is grossly
mis-marketed um they're a phenomenal
company they've been around for 30 years
they are all their stuff meets all of
the
epa regulations and it is on the safer
choice most of their products are in the
the safety choice uh what is it safer
safer choice products that are
registered by the epa and the ap epa
when they register those products they
don't just register the regular product
they register every single ingredient of
those products and then they determine
whether or not it meets uh its
competitors brands that have more toxic
fumes and stuff like that otoban is a
phenomenal product today we just happen
to be talking about bleach and because
bleach will like bleach your clothes and
it stains things and you know people are
scared of it and it smells bad and all
that stuff and i'm not knocking the
product because there's a very good use
for it and when used properly you can be
safe all right so that said um uh denise
said i'll jump in here real quick denise
said former custodian and homemaker now
wear white t-shirt if you can to prevent
bleach stains absolute
absolutely label put it on a high shelf
uh yeah that's a great a great
suggestion and if you are a homeowner
and you have that ability that's awesome
some house cleaners that are
professionals are required to wear their
uniforms while they're cleaning and so
in this particular situation they may
not be able to wear a white t-shirt if
that's the case what we do want to do is
we want to wear our bib apron
and the bib apron
is
the one that i recommend is adjustable
and this allows you to put it on over
your head and then adjust it so that it
fits you perfectly and get it up tight
over your clothes like scooch it up near
your neck so that it covers you and it
doesn't get any of your clothes this one
also goes all the way down past my knees
almost like three quarters past my knees
down almost to the the floor um and the
thing i like about this is it is water
resistant so it will repel water and
it's it doesn't absorb so fastly into
your clothes if you get some bleach on
it it will stain but it's not going to
stain your clothes and so i really like
it for that reason these are fairly
inexpensive um but i do recommend that
you wear something to protect your
uniform for the very same reason i
recommend and this is this this goes
against everything that we've trained
before
but i recommend that when you are doing
bleach and a shower that you also wear
shoe covers now we wear shoe covers as
house cleaners when we're inside
someone's home
because we want to prevent ourselves
from tracking in dirt from outside and
so if we are at a customer's house and
we are um
we are wearing our shoe covers when we
get inside their house that's cool but
we usually take them off when we get
inside the shower and the reason for
that is when you get inside the shower
we don't want to slip and fall right but
for this particular situation we're not
going to be climbing inside the shower
unless we absolutely have to what we're
going to be doing is we're going to be
reaching inside the shower we're going
to be spraying and then we're going to
be dipping back outside the shower again
so this is for our feet in the event
that there's any overspray we don't want
it on our nice expensive shoes and so i
do recommend these shoe covers while
you're doing the bleach application okay
so for for this particular time we're
not going to take the shoe covers off
when we go inside the bathroom we're
going to leave them on
and i recommend the kind of shoe covers
again i've got links below so that you
guys can learn more about this you can
add some to your card if you want um i
have gone through all of the products
that
i'm sharing with you today and i found
the very best prices for these products
and i will i will tell you i do make a
commission if you buy them and that's
not why i'm here you're going to buy
them anyway i want you to buy the right
ones and i want you to understand the
products and then i want you to save
some money at the same time okay and if
you can do something else without
spending the money i will tell you that
as well but i want you to buy the right
stuff the first time there's nothing
more that makes me sad that people buy a
whole bunch of stuff and then it's the
wrong stuff either they bought the cheap
version and it fell apart or it was not
it wasn't quality and it didn't do the
job or
they bought something that they got
price gouge done right so i just want to
tell you but to have the ones with the
treads on the bottom that's a non-slip
protective
protection and so for all of the shoe
covers that you buy these are not the
cheapest on the market but these will
prevent with the non-skids these will
prevent you from slipping like on
hardwood floors or whatever we buy one
kind and we use them for all of our
cleaning so if you're on ceramic tile
floors if you're on hardwood floors if
you are cleaning anywhere in a
customer's house this is going to
prevent your shoes from tracking in
anything from outside and some house
cleaners have asked me the question so
i'll just answer it now should we take
our shoes off when we go inside a
customer's house and the answer is
absolutely not because you are on your
feet as a house cleaner all day and so
if you're cleaning from sun up till
sundown that's a lot of time
that you're you're putting pressure on
your back your hips your knees your
spine you need the support that good
shock absorbers can provide from really
great quality athletic shoes and so the
shoe that i use is a i believe it's an
excursion a trail excursion it's a cross
cross shoe between
a trail running shoe and a running shoe
and so it's got a lot of shock
absorbency in it it's got the high
arches it's got a really flexible toe
box i'm not here to sell your shoes but
you need to be wearing shoes when you're
cleaning house so even if it's your own
house if it's someone else's house if
you're cleaning for an airbnb please
wear your shoes and then just cover a
shoe cover to protect your your feet so
that you're not upsetting a homeowner
that's like i don't want to use my house
or whatever you need to wear shoes to
protect your back your spine your hips
and your knees okay so i'm glad we said
that yay i feel so much better already
all right one more piece of personal
protective equipment while we are
talking about the shoe covers
is i want to talk for a second about
gloves and gloves are really important i
always wear nitrile gloves and i like
the nitrile gloves better than the latex
i find that over the long haul they are
um
they they they work with more house
cleaners some house cleaners have latex
allergies the nitrile seems to just be a
good middle of the road
glove that you can wear and i like it
because they're really durable they
don't rip as easy as some of the other
brands that i've seen and the thing that
i like about them is if i'm running my
hands across a countertop i can feel the
grit with my fingers with the gloves on
and so i can tell like oh is this dirty
or is it clean even without looking at
it like sometimes you go to clean
something and you hit like a a piece of
gunk and you can't tell that there's
gunk this allows you to to sense that
while you're wearing these gloves this
will also protect your hands from
getting bleach on them okay and it's
really important because even if it's
just an over spray and you're using that
that motion with a
spray bottle it can leak and it can get
on your hands and it can eat through
your hands because it's a very strong
chemical right and we want to be
sensitive to chemicals especially if
we're cleaning all day all right i'm
going to stop for just a second answer
your questions and then we'll jump back
in uh marilyn says best product found
for the bathroom is clorox cleaner and
bleach spray and done okay yes that is
awesome
maryland also says if you have hard
water stains in the toilet and you've
tried everything endless chemicals
didn't work you can clean without
chemicals if you want get some gloves
and like grit
wet dry sandpaper and go to town so
we're not going to talk about cleaning
toilets today because we are going to
talk about bleach but i do want us to be
really really cautious and that's that's
an excellent tool thanks for
recommending that um i do want to
recommend that while we're using bleach
again to be very painfully clear that
this is a specialty product not to be
used by anyone unless they've had proper
training on your team so if you are
bringing house cleaners in it is your
job as a professional that you do
provide personal protective equipment
um
one of the personal protective equipment
that we also recommend are safety
glasses and these safety glasses are
really great because they wrap around
your eyes
and it will prevent you if you are
spraying that any
back spray would flip inside your eyes
so it's not going to completely cover
your eyes like if you were to have
goggles that were sealed which would be
awesome if you covered those two but
that's like the respiratory mask most
people are not going to go
that severe
your basic
tools that you are required by osha to
have are enough that will remind a house
cleaner that you are in an environment
where you must be careful and it's that
being on high alert and that situational
awareness that protects us it's going to
help you protect yourself from spilling
stuff you're going to be very careful
about where you stand you're going to be
careful about if you lean up against a
shower that you've just sprayed you're
going to be careful about all of those
things and you want to make sure that
you're very careful and the personal
protective equipment from top to bottom
and that's your eyes your face mask your
gloves your shoe covers your apron you
are from head to toe you're covered and
so that's just going to be an awareness
to you that
i'm i got to be careful right i'm doing
this bleach project
all right uh smoky of storm and says and
if you're using bleach you want to
protect your skin and your feet
from bleach it can make skin start to
peel if exposed for a long time yes
that's true we want to prevent prevent
all of our skin from touching it and we
want to especially prevent our eyes
getting it in our eyes on the safety
data sheet going back to the precautions
it is very harmful to your eyes and if
you do get it in your eyes you want to
stop what you're doing and you want to
flush it with water all right so that
said i want to jump over to what is the
process of using bleach okay so once
we've showed up and i said already this
is a special project right if you are
going to a customer's house for the very
first time and you know you're going to
do a bleach this is a special project so
you need you need to bill for it you
need to bring your special training your
special equipment and your special caddy
that has your bleach and then also your
ozone generator this is an ozone
generator we need to talk about this for
a second it's about the size of my head
and so you can see
how big it is it's really not that big
at all
it comes with a three prong plug
and so it fits into a regular outlet
um
can you see that
and then this is the other side of it so
it's a little plug that fits into the
back of this right here
all right and then there's a big fan on
the back here which is going to help
circulate the air and on the front there
are different timing timings so you can
set it for 20 minutes 30 minutes 60
minutes 90 minutes all the way up to
three hours and then it has a hold
button down here so you can see the hold
and you can turn it on and leave it on
if you need it but for most
circumstances like if you're in a master
bathroom and you're going to be using
bleach probably 20 or 30 minutes will
work now let's talk about ozone for a
second and what is this this is an ozone
generating machine and the purpose of
having an ozone generating machine is
that it's going to remove the smell from
the bleach that is what causes us to go
like that if we breathe it okay but
ozone also does that to you ozone also
creates its own nasty smell so if you've
ever been outside
and there's like lightning
and you go outside and you smell that it
just kind of smells like a musty dirt
smell and you're kind of like
like that that's ozone
so
having bleach and ozone in the same
place is just like double nasty right so
what we're going to do is we're going to
create a ozone chamber and then we're
going to get out of the bathroom while
it does its work now here's how ozone
works um regular oxygen that we breathe
is o2 and it has two molecules of oxygen
okay that's normal everyday oxygen that
we breathe the ozone which are little
short rays from uv that come from like
the light of the sun that is o1 and so
like when lightning strikes for example
it connects to the the regular oxygen
molecules and now instead of having o2
you have o3 and the o3 is a really
unstable oxygen so what happens is it
kind of like fights to get back to its
equilibrium which it dissipates one of
those oxygen molecules and as a result
of it it's kind of cool but what it does
is it grabs the odors the the molecules
that have odors in them and it breaks it
down and decomposes it and oxidizes it
then it goes back to normal so what
we've discovered over the course of time
is that by having an ozone generator we
can use it for cleaning chemicals like
bleach so this becomes a really great
powerhouse and the reason this becomes a
special project because when you go to a
customer's house and you're bringing
extra equipment you got to pay for the
extra equipment you have to know how to
use the extra equipment it's extra
training because it's not a regular
process that we're going to do like when
we're regularly cleaning a customer's
house right
so there are rules and regulations for
using an ozone generator so if you are
going to clean a customer's house with
bleach and you bring your ozone
generator you also have to bring a
couple other things so one of the things
that you're going to bring with you is a
bath towel and
i have um added a couple of bath towels
down here and it's because you need a
really heavy duty durable bath towel it
doesn't matter what kind it doesn't
matter if it's old it doesn't matter if
it's stained it doesn't it doesn't
matter um but it's going to be a great
big heavy duty durable thick plush bath
towel and you're going to lay it down
and you're going to roll it sideways so
that it will cover the bottom of an
entire door and what we're going to do
is we're going to block off
all of the air that's circulating in the
room now you'll notice in really fancy
homes especially they've got these huge
palladium windows in their bathroom and
all that's in all this beautiful light
they've got these big tubs and big
showers but they have really poor
ventilation in many homes because those
windows do not open
and so they might have a little fan
which they're required by law to have
that meets the builder's code but the
builders the the fan in the bathroom
often doesn't have proper ventilation
and then in the next room they might
have a bedroom or something and if the
windows are not open
it's common to get all kinds of mold
inside these really fancy expensive
showers and so if you're going inside
one of those bathrooms what you're going
to do is you're going to close off the
bathroom you'll go inside you'll spray
the bathroom with bleach and then you'll
close the bathroom off and you will turn
on the the ozone generator and then
you're going to leave and go clean the
rest of the house while it does the
bleach part and while it does the ozone
part okay so what happens is in this
ceramic that inside this machine it has
a ceramic plate and this electrically
creates that ozone it's just like
lightning and it creates the ozone which
is like a smog and it has that really
awful nasty smell to it we don't want
that smell circulating through the house
because now you've got bleach and you
have ozone that would be circulating
through the house and so the rule of
thumb is if you're going to use an ozone
machine get everybody out of the house
okay don't use it with people plants or
pets inside the house because it's not
healthy and it can be toxic to plants
for example it can kill your plants as
far as people and pets it's just going
to make you sick it's like when you
breathe fumes and you get that
feeling in your lungs it's the same kind
of thing so we don't want that to happen
as far as um
us breathing that uh smokey if stormwind
says uh used to use ozone generators
when guests would smoke in the rooms it
gets rid of cigarette smoke smell and it
works awesome that is so true and i'm so
glad you brought that up thank you so
much there are lots of airbnb hosts that
use the ozone generators between guests
to get rid of stinky stock smile or if
there is uh like if they did smoke or if
they smoked marijuana or something on
the property there were no smoking
policies sometimes even if they vape or
if they burned incense it can be really
nasty smells that you're not accustomed
to i know another one is cooking with
curry curry has a really strong smell
and so if you have an airbnb and then
you come in to clean and you find that
whoa somebody loved curry while they
were here and they did lots of cooking
and it's that the smell has lingered
this is a great way to get that out of
the air for airbnb hosts and one of the
reasons it's so popular with airbnb
hosts i'll share this with you it is
also really really popular with flood
and fire restoration companies and for
the reason that if there's been a fire
in the house and the smoke alarm goes
off even if there wasn't a fire but
there was lots of smoke for example if
something overheated or something you
know burnt pizza or whatever it is
um
the smell of that can get stuck on
things like oil paintings
and you can't grab cleaning solution and
go spray oil paintings and get the smell
off you can't do that and so it the
smell the stink and the smell will get
embedded into like fabrics and wall
hangings and drapes and carpets and
furniture and clothing and if you have a
basement for example let's say if you
have a carpeted basement that is close
to um the the cement floor oftentimes it
can if it rains or it's moist outside it
can absorb a moisture that's in the
cement and it can bring that into the
the basement where there's not a lot of
circulation and then it will smell bad
and you have these musty dank smells you
can grab an ozone generator and you can
turn it on and you can create an ozone
chamber and then you can lock the door
and leave and while you're gone it can
do the ozone the ozone thing uh the
ozone we want to leave it for about 20
to 30 minutes and then the ozone breaks
down it's got like 50 life every half
hour so the next half hour it's going to
be 50 percent less potent as what it was
before and then the next half hour it's
going to be 50 of that then the next
half hour it's going to be 50
of that so it breaks down over two or
three hours and then it doesn't smell
like anything at all so it's like coming
in after a rainstorm
and everything has broken down properly
and then you're not smelling it so that
it's not um it's not you know hurting
your lungs or any of those things
so uh one of the things that i do want
to mention if you are using it as a as a
smell as a smell replacer as a smell
destroyer
just be aware that it's not great for
people plants or pets and if you are
going to use it
while you are at a customer's house
the proper way to do it is to lock the
bottom of the door if you look in any
room of your house if you if you are in
a room right now where there's a door if
you look in the bottom of that door
you'll probably notice there's about
this much
underneath the door where um
air can get through
that's what you want to block with the
towel so that nothing comes through so
the towel is going to be on the outside
of the door the the ozone chamber is
going to be inside the bathroom you're
going to turn the ozone on inside the
bathroom you're going to put it at about
vanity level so that it circulates
evenly through the room you're going to
turn off any air conditioning and any
heat if you can
if you can't let's say you're in an
apartment complex and
it's central air and heat you're not
going to be able to go in and like oh
hey can like everyone in the building
turn off their air well while i use the
ozone you're not going to be able to do
that right nor nor should you
so um one of the things that i've linked
to below are magnetic vent covers and
the typical vent
you'll if you look there's probably one
in every room by builders code there has
to be a vent in every room so there's
probably one in a small room there are
probably two or three in a large room
and so one of the things that we want to
do is we want to put a magnetic piece
over the top of that vent just to block
it and when you put them up near the
vent or
on a floor vent it usually smacks on and
there's a lot of metal there so it holds
it in place
the ones that i've linked to are i
believe they are uh 13 by eight or
something and the average vent is five
and a half by 12. so this is going to
over over cover it it's going to do its
job and then if you have a big big vent
you may want to put two of them on there
just to cover the central air so that if
the central air is on it's just going to
block those while you're doing the ozone
thing and that's going to protect you
it's going to protect the smells
circulating through the house because
there's nothing worse than having a
really strong bleach smell and then
really strong ozone smell while you're
trying to clean somewhere else in the
house that that too will make you sick
so we don't want to do that
uh let's see
uh we have we've got so many folks here
hi glide and glow hi denise hi nick
smokey wins anna violatex uh juliet you
guys i'm so excited that you came to
spend some time with me today this is so
cool and i just i really appreciate your
comments and thank you maryland as well
okay so one of the things that i want to
talk about is if you are inside the
shower there's one more thing i want to
mention when we talk about towels and it
is um
terry cloths we're going to use terry
claws and i use the white ones
especially if i'm doing bleach for the
the fact that uh if for any reason i
spill something it's white this goes
back to the the conversation about
having a white t-shirt if you're using a
white terry cloth it's not going to
stain as bad
when you step out of the shower if for
any reason you stepped on something in
the shower and you stepped out whatever
you step on is going to be the
customer's floor we want to make sure
that before we do the process we remove
the bath mat take it outside of the
bathroom we don't want to risk getting
any bleach whatsoever on the customer's
bath net where the shower is when you
step out of the shower you're going to
step out onto your terry cloths and so
now you've got your shoe covers on and
you're stepping onto a terry cloth
that's going to absorb anything so that
if you step out on the customer's floor
you're not going to get any gunk on the
customer's floor i do recommend before
you leave the bathroom that you take
those shoe covers off and then when you
go outside the bathroom that you get
another set of shoe covers for the rest
of the customer's house we don't want to
risk at all under any circumstances
having gotten bleach on the bottom of
your shoes and then tracking it anywhere
in the customer's house because you are
responsible again it's in your care
custody and control and if you use
bleach you're 100 responsible for
whatever happens so if you have to wipe
up any bleach and i'm not kidding even
wiping up
even wiping up the bottle the side of
the bottle if some spilled on the side
of the bottle and you have to wipe it up
you want to make sure that it is a
hundred percent wiped up before you take
this bottle and put it back inside your
cleaning caddy you do not want to stain
your cleaning caddy you don't want the
bottle to leak anywhere in the
customer's house so if you've used this
bottle to spray bleach in a customer's
house you're going to want to rinse the
bottle from head to toe and then dry it
off with a
terry cloth and that way you're covered
and then there are no surprises so as
part of the training that we do for all
of our employees or if you're an airbnb
host and you work in airbnbs you want to
do the same process there's nothing
worse
than having a really nice dark carpet in
a bedroom right off the side of the
bathroom and then you walk out
with your supplies and you leak bleach
on it or something and then you got to
buy them a new whatever it is a new
carpet a new rug a new whatever so it
it's your responsibility you got to be
super careful all right let's see do i
have any questions about the products
that we've talked so far
denise says yes please don't mix bleach
with fumes like ammonia it's toxic and
deadly i think that goes without saying
but i'm so glad that denise brought that
up we don't mix
anything with bleach
ever we don't mix anything with bleach
ever let me say that again we don't mix
bleach with anything ever okay so you
can dilute bleach and we use the word
dilute you can dilute bleach with water
and that's technically mixing but we're
going to use the word mixing we don't
mix with anything because we want to
know and we want all of our employees to
know that mixing bleach like denise said
can be deadly and every single year
there are house cleaners and homeowners
that go to the hospital because they've
mixed bleach with something because in
the back of their mind oh it did such a
great job with this and this does such a
great job over here if i mix them it
will be twice as good right not twice as
good twice as stupid and i have to say
that because we are not for the most
part we are not chemists and i'm really
really keen on this you if you are not a
chemist and you did not go to school for
chemistry and you are not in a lab
situation where it's a controlled
environment where they have eye wash
stations and they have you know
emergency
ventilators and all this kind of stuff
to protect you if something goes wrong
you have no business no business
guessing on your own like oh this is
this is not like cooking where you're
mixing a couple of ingredients together
we're talking about really specific
varieties of chemicals that have been
tested in controlled environments for a
very specific task okay and so with that
in mind we have to we have to respect
the bleach which is very very very
strong i love the clorox company for the
the things that they've done i just want
to stop and give them a shout out uh
during the pandemic
uh clorox had to kind of retool all of
the stuff that it was doing and it
became
a pandemic awareness about cleaning
sanitizing and disinfecting and the
clorox company went to task and they
started producing
clorox and bleach in 55 gallon drums
because 155 gallon drum would clean 14
000 hospital rooms and the hospitals
were overwhelmed with people that were
rushing to the hospital because of the
of the covet virus and so because of
that their attention was how do we serve
and so in a place where it was tough i
mean remember in the at the beginning of
the pandemic how nobody nobody could get
cleaning supplies you would go to a
store and there would be like nothing
nothing there's nothing there
you couldn't get the cleaning supplies
because the shipments had stopped so all
of the the chemical uh products that
they used to make clorox and all the
stuff that they all the all their
processing had come to a grinding halt
as well and they were paying exorbitant
fees to try to to stay in mass
production and create the stuff that
they normally do and so they were
charging the same prices they weren't
doing any price gouging whatsoever and
they were working overtime literally
around the clock 24 7 to try to provide
enough clorox that it would support the
the people that were doing all the
disinfecting and all the cleaning and
all that stuff and so i really applaud
them because they jump through enormous
hoops that cost them millions of dollars
in order to be able to satisfy that need
and granted they're a public company i
mean they're they're here to make money
but the things that they did went so far
above and beyond just regular customer
service and to be able to just ship out
these big 55 gallon drums to help the
hospitals and to try to keep everything
sanitized to protect our health so i'm a
really really big fan of the company and
i love the fact that even though they
have this very strong chemical that they
were able to provide service now one of
the things that's really cool about the
clorox company
because we got asked a lot of questions
during the pandemic about can i use this
on my hardwood floor to disinfect my
hardwood floor
guys can we have a conversation for a
second about hardwood floors
why are you disinfecting it like most
people don't eat off their hardwood
floor like the hardwood floors for
walking on and if you walk inside a
house and you take off your shoes for
the most part and you're wandering
around your own house
um you shouldn't have like really dirty
floors and if you do you can sweep and
mop them but we don't need to be
spraying bleach on our hardwood floors
and during the pandemic i saw so much
property damage of people that used
bleach the wrong way i got calls from
churches and they said you know people
came in and they sprayed bleach all over
the wood like where people put their
hands when they kneel down to pray
or the racks where the the hymnals are
um they said they sprayed them on the
the cloth which are those velvet pews
and then they would leave it on for 10
minutes hoping that it would disinfect
and it ruined
i mean bleach is bleach it's gonna
bleach it's gonna take the color right
out of that but it did it bleached the
pews it ruined the velvet it ruined the
wood it ate through the varnish on the
church pews the church benches they
mopped the floors with bleach i mean
you're not gonna believe the kind of
property damage there were people going
inside office buildings and for the few
people that were still working before
the the stay-at-home mandates
there were people that were
spraying like these really nice office
desks with bleach and leaving it on
there for 10 minutes it would just eat
through the varnish
and then like they're like oh no what
did i do and then the offices would call
me and the churches were calling me and
i'm like well the good news is your your
cleaner is insured right i'm sure like
you hired a reputable cleaner and
they're like oh no like the church was
like no no we had parishioners that
volunteered and then i was like
oh no this is on you i mean like you're
not you're not covered right and as a as
a cleaner
we had to have like these emergency
conferences and tell all of our cleaners
this is in your care custody and control
and if it comes out of your spray bottle
and you are paid to be the cleaner you
are also being paid to know how this
works and this is the reason why i say
bleach is a special project it requires
special training special equipment and i
mean you're going to be bringing with
you stuff that we don't bring to our
normal jobs right if you're going to be
doing an ozone job you're going to be
bringing with you special equipment and
so for that you should charge a special
fee and if we do a special project like
if we have a couple of showers that
we're doing we'll just bundle those
together and we'll add that maybe to the
first cleaning but that's going to be an
extra 100 or so to come in and treat
that whole shower but it's going to cost
them a hundred dollars anyway because if
you don't use the bleach then when you
come in you got to get your little scrub
brush and what are you going to use
cleanser or something and then you're
going to have to clean that and it's
going to take you an hour an hour and a
half to do it anyway right so you might
as well do the first time and kill those
micro organisms that you find with the
pink slime and the mold and all that
stuff i'd rather treat the customer the
right way give them the right kind of
cleaning and then they might have to pay
a little bit more but they're going to
pay a little bit more anyway right if it
takes you an hour and a half to clean
their shower
why not have it just take the normal
amount of time but you you cleaned it
the right way and you were able to kill
that bacteria so that's my that's my
that's how i feel about that
ah
okay so i've got a couple of comments
here hi jay hi romy denise you guys it's
so good to see you on a saturday morning
this is fun
uh violet
violet xoxo xoxo says uh people today
think you can just use bleach for
everything scary how people go bananas
using it that's true that's true it is
it is scary how people think it's good
for everything and like i said it's a
maintenance
i mean it's a special project and then
we do maintenance cleaning after that so
i get asked the question a lot
especially if we've done a
a deep clean on a shower which is a
special project and we use the bleach
i get a lot of questions where people
say um
after the bleach how do i maintain the
shower and it comes down to training
your customers how to clean their
showers properly and so whether it's a
bathtub or whether it's a shower that
has a glass door that we have to
squeegee at the bottom uh one of the
things that i recommend and i'm i'm a
really big fan of this there's a product
and it's a mallory um
do i have one here i do check it out i
have one here
if it is a
scrub sponge that has a nylon net over
the top of it and then on the other side
it has a squeegee and this has a really
long handle i'm not a fan of the long
handle but this is the only way i can
find it this is actually found in the
automotive department and this is
designed for getting bugs off the
windshields of cars now sometimes you'll
go to a gas station and in the little
thing with the water in it you see these
this is phenomenal and this is the best
tool that i've ever seen
for
cleaning your bathroom shower and then
squeegeeing it down and so i've linked
to this below and here's how i use it
i grabbed the one that i hope this is
not gross i grabbed the one from my
bathroom this morning and it's older so
it's kind of a little bit you know used
and it's wet but um what i did is i just
took a pipe cutter and i just cut the
the handle in half so that it's more
user friendly for my shower okay and so
what what i do then after i am ready to
replace it like if i'm ready to replace
it it just unscrews like this so then i
can unscrew the short little handle and
i don't have to keep recutting it
because i can only get it you can only
buy it with the long handle anyway um
this is phenomenal so going back to the
question we had about the soap scum how
do you get rid of the soap scum hang on
i just dropped this there it disappeared
and i'm back
i use in the shower dawn dish soap so
this is what don dish soap looks like
most of you are familiar with it i know
in the european continent it's called
fairy so fairy or dawn this is what we
use and i love the blue stuff i think
it's just great
i i have added to the links here also a
pump container and it doesn't matter
what kind of pump container that you use
any kind of pump container will work
um but i think it should be clear and
this is my own personal preference for
this reason i can always see at a glance
how much i have am i getting close am i
getting down to the bottom you know i
can see if i can see it's also um
anybody that's in the shower and this
one goes in my shower so i'm the only
one that's there if you share a shower
with someone else you may want to put a
label on it so they know what it is and
put the the tape over the front of it so
that other people would know that um
what it is right because that's just
chemical safety wise but i like the
clear container for this reason so after
a shower this is how you do a
maintenance clean on a shower after
you've already done the bleach you just
put a little couple of drops on the top
here
while your shower is wet
this goes back to the concept of uh
you know how when you soak a pot and pan
like it has gunk it's caked on the
bottom of it and it's not coming off
with the scrubby and how you like fill
it up with hot soap and water and you
put dish soap in it this is the same
concept so you're inside the shower it's
hot it's steamy you've got nice hot
water in there and it's been going for a
couple of minutes everything in the
shower is loose so if you have a whole
shower door full of soap scum a little
bit of dish soap on the side and this is
a sponge with a scrubby but it's not
going to scratch the glass so then you
can use this and go back and forth along
the sides of the shower glass and you
want to go up and around the corners and
around the handles and because this is a
scrubby it's not going to scratch but
you can also go around the hardware you
remember how in the video i said don't
use the bleach on the hardware which is
going to be your faucet your shower head
on a hose the metal rim around the doors
we don't want to use bleach on that
because it will eat away the finish we
don't want to do that but you can with
this go up and down all the hardware and
around the faucet you can grab the
shower head on a hose and go up and down
on both sides and clean it with the soap
just imagine if it was a pot in a pan
and you were using dish soap so it's
like the scrubby with the dish soap has
the same exact effect and the dish soap
is a degreaser so back to the question
about the soap scum it removes the soap
scum so for regular everyday cleaning
you just clean the walls with the soap
and your sponge then you use the shower
head on a hose and you hose the entire
shower down
when you're done with that you turn the
squeegee over and then you just squeegee
the walls
now your shower looks brand new and when
you get to a customer's house the
customer has done this process the
showers are going to be super easy to
clean and if we train our customers to
do that it's going to save them a lot of
money because it's not going to take us
a half hour every single time we come to
their house to clean their shower and so
with this this is safe for use on
fiberglass it's safe for ceramic tile if
you have like a ceramic tile shower like
the one we saw in the video it's safe
for shower glass it's just phenomenal so
while this was designed
for automobiles and the bugs and the tar
and stuff it's fantastic for showers and
so i'm a really big fan of this all
right so with that um i think i think
i've covered everything
i didn't cover everything oh my goodness
i forgot okay i have one more thing to
tell you when we get out of the shower
and we've already done the whole process
with the bleach and we use the ozone
generator and then we left for a little
bit i forgot to tell you what happens
when we come back when we come back into
the bathroom we're not going to mix
remember how we said we're not going to
mix bleach with anything
there's residue of bleach in that shower
because we just sprayed the whole entire
shower from top to bottom with bleach so
there are still there's still residue of
bleach we're not going to be bringing in
any other chemicals to put inside that
shower okay not cool so what's going to
happen is when we come back in the room
is going to smell nice it's not going to
smell like bleach it's not going to
smell like ozone we've been gone for a
couple hours we cleaned the rest of the
house we're going to come back in now
everything's going to be sort of tidy
like all the gunk in the in the shower
is pretty much going to be gone it's
just gonna look like oh no somebody was
in here and they did some weird stuff
and now they left right you're gonna
remove the towel remove the the
things that are sitting in front of the
shower you're gonna remove the bleach
you're gonna remove you're gonna pour
the bleach back into the container you
put all your stuff away and that goes in
a special kit okay you're going to put
all that stuff back away inside that kit
you're also going to bring
a steamer this is a handheld steamer
it's one of my favorites this is the
bissell steamer and this steamer is
really great for a whole lot of
non-chemical cleaning and i like to use
it in addition to the bleach because
it's just steam we're talking about just
water to combat whatever we just did
inside the shower okay so the bleach is
going to get most of it out we're going
to come in with our steamer now this
steamer i love this steamer for a couple
reasons it comes with this kit and this
kit has 25 attachments in it and it has
everything from the attachments that you
use for the barbecue grill to the grout
brushes that you use if you're doing
grout i showed you one of the grout
brushes inside the video but it has just
a whole bunch of attachments this also
has the attachment that the little
bonnet goes on that i showed you inside
the video where you can use it to remove
soap scum with nothing but
the steam and a couple things about the
steam we're just going to use regular
water we're not going to use vinegar in
here we're not going to use essential
oils we're not going to use anything but
water and i get asked this question a
lot because i don't know people are
tempted to add other stuff
the steamer is designed to remove 99.9
percent of bacteria with just the steam
it's the heat of the water that makes it
so sanitary right it's like boiling
something remember back in the days
where
a kid would drop the the binky or the
pacifier on the floor and we would boil
it in water the reason we did that is
because the boiling of the water would
disinfect and it would it would kill the
germs by the time the kid is one why you
just pick it off the floor you blow it
off and you give it back
but in the beginning when they're new we
would boil them so that there's no germs
right this goes along the same concept
and the thing that i like about this
unit
is because it's just water um we're not
mixing anything it's it's easy to use
when you're done with the job and you
dump the water out we always store it
with the door open and that way the air
can circulate and dry it out so that it
doesn't build bacteria inside our
reservoir okay so a couple rules about
using a steamer and this has a really
long cord one of the reasons i really
like this unit it has a super long cord
so that i don't need to bring a
extension cord an extension cord with me
on the job
but the other thing that i like about
that steamer and i just happen to have
this with me is it also has another
adapter where you can use it as a
regular mop and this just pops off so
that you can use this and attach this to
the handheld unit so if you have to go
up to the top of the shower and you're
going to steam off you remember how
you've probably seen some of these these
online hacks where there's like gunk on
a shower head and people take like
vinegar and they put it in a bag they
try to tie a twisty around it and leave
it overnight this is all kind of weird
stuff
if you're using a steamer and this is a
great way to do this you just attach
this to the steamer head
it goes something like
this and now you have a long stick so it
allows you in a tall shower even to go
up to the top of the shower head on a
hose or the shower head and you can
steam that and just by steaming it you
can remove all of the gunk so it's a
seamless process then when you go to mop
the floors there's a little tongue and
groove here and the tongue and groove
just fits right inside here i don't know
if you can see it
but anyway it just goes like this
and once it snaps in place you hook that
on and then you can go ahead and you can
mop and steam like your ceramic tile
floors and again no chemicals are
required and so this you can use is
either a damp mop a dry mop or a steam
mop and so i love it for that fact
because a lot of times like if you have
hardwood floors
or you have luxury vinyl plank flooring
and you don't want to use steam because
of course you don't want to use it
unless you absolutely have to for like
dog puke or you know whatever
um this gives you the opportunity to to
do that clean up with the damp or the
dry mop and so there are lots of
opportunities for using it but i love
the steamer because it has so many uh
different utilities and the steamer
we do carry on a regular maintenance job
with us we do carry this with us but
it's also one of our best and favorite
tools for the special projects that we
do because like if a customer wants you
to to clean out their freezer when you
unplug the freezer you've got five to
eight hours of defrosting before it's
actually gonna um make itself
you know
what do you call it defrosted and so you
can go in here after it's unplugged and
don't hit the coils directly but you can
hit all the areas in the shelves around
it and the as it drops it's going to air
out all that other area and you can do
it in about i don't know a tenth of the
time so we use this for a lot for the
the
defrosting of freezers and stuff like
that you can also use it on ovens inside
ovens if there's somebody with chemical
safety uh chemical sensitivities
you can also use this for that uh in the
video you saw we also used it to clean
up the rest of the shower if there's any
residue in the shower after we've
already rinsed it come in we're gonna
rinse the shower with the shower head on
a hose then we're going to use our
steamer for the last little bit of
whatever we have to do in that shower to
get it clean so for using bleach bleach
when you absolutely have to make sure
that you take your precautions and make
sure that you're wearing your personal
protective equipment make sure that when
you come into to do the after cleaning
when you get ready to do the actual
cleaning because again bleach is not a
cleaner it's a
disinfectant
what you're going to do then is you're
going to just going to use your steamer
and that way you can use any of the
attachments that we have that will do
the job for what you need so if you
decided before you started the job that
you have um
that you have some
mold or something on the walls you may
want to go over it with a steamer
attachment that is designed and this is
what this looks like that it's designed
for the grout so that it just gently
removes all of that and it steams it and
disinfects it as as you go
so
let's see
we've got uh some questions here and i
wanna i really wanna make sure that i
get all these answered
uh jay said i had to report our
housekeeping depart for spring bleach in
the air after cleaning a room in my
hospital
oh
that's not cool
i'm sorry that that happened
again it comes down to just being aware
there are a lot of people that don't
know the rules i know during the
pandemic we had a lot of people that
didn't know the rules and so they were
they were using and misusing bleach
and uh back the back
back to the clorox company they made
sure that during the pandemic when
people were spraying bleach on floors
and leaving them on floors they came up
with a clorox
wipe it would go right over like a
swiffer duster for example and it fit
the swiffer dusters perfectly so you can
use existing tools that are out on the
market they weren't even selling new
tools this was just stop whatever you're
doing you know with mopping with the
bleach and use these wipes that have a
limited amount of chemicals on them and
it's it's not a bleach um
it wasn't a bleach situation but it was
like 99.9 sanitizing of the floors and
we determined that that was good enough
because for most people 99.9
was sufficient for flooring
unlike jay we're not doing
medical procedures on our hardwood
floors in our homes for the most part
and so
i mean i hope not at all unless you know
i i hope not at all
so these these tools that we use it
comes down to are you are you working
smart not hard and are you learning the
proper tools and techniques and so
that's what this whole um dog and pony
show is today
to let you know about the the proper
ways that we're using this all right i
want to open this up for questions do we
have any other questions here um i i see
lots of people saying hey how you doing
and hey how you doing back uh nestor and
denise and uh pam pam says could you
please explain the difference between
clorox anywhere hard surface cleaner pet
friendly which i can't find anymore and
clorox hard surface cleaner commercial
grade
uh so i don't know without looking at
the safety data sheets the specifics
between those two products
and one of the things that i want to pay
attention to is clorox can only be used
on sealed surfaces and so it's not
designed for porous surfaces and so how
do you know if you have a sealed surface
so if you take some water and you spray
it on a surface like let's say that you
spray it on a porcelain sink and it
beads up on the porcelain sink it
doesn't sink in then you know you have a
sealed surface and it's okay to use the
clorox spray and the clark spray would
be the dilution version that we're using
inside a spray bottle and this is three
one ounces to 32 ounces of water so
we're diluting it and that would be the
equivalent of one of the ready-to-use
sprays and that's something you need to
be aware of if you go to a store they
have concentrates and they have ready to
use when i buy a gallon of bleach like
this this is a concentrate and so this
is what we're talking about diluting and
so diluting this is we're not going to
use it full strength except in those
icky showers and exactly how i explained
it that's the only way we're going to
use it and for the rest of everything
else that we use it for i think it's
going to be a diluted version
um if you buy a ready-to-use spray
you're going to go in and there's like a
spray with a fancy bottle and it says
clorox bathroom spray or something
that's a diluted version it's going to
be the equivalent of the three pumps and
the rest of it is water so you're mostly
paying for water and they have different
varieties some smell like you know
lavender some smell like lemon they have
different scents that some are made for
the bathroom some are stronger
what i recommend is that you read the
labels and then you make sure you only
use it on what it says because here's
something that most people don't know
when you use a cleaning chemical
and you use it as is directed by the
manufacturer you're good and if you use
it for other things and i see a lot of
tick-tock hacks don't get me started on
tick-tock hacks but i see tick-tock
hacks where people are like mixing
chemicals and stuff and they're using it
inconsistent with the way that the
manufacturer intended it not only can
that be toxic but
if it ruins the surface or it plugs the
toilet or it ruins whatever it's not
under warranty it will completely void
the warranty on whatever you have
whether it's flooring whether it's an
appliance whether it's the
fridge a sink a stove a cabinet a
countertop whatever if you use the
products inconsistent with the the
manufacturer's specifications they will
not they will not stand good for it
they're not responsible and so don't try
to call them and say oh i used your
product and it ruined sentences you're
supposed to know better
so um yeah please don't use the tick
tock hacks
most of them are just for entertainment
only
and i hope that nobody ever gets hurt
from the
damage that's caused by those all right
so i i said that okay let's see do we
have any other comments here
uh someone's here said to mix bleach
with thick toilet cleaner and leave it
to sit on grout uh no we're not going to
do that i don't know who said that but
we're not going to do that we just
agreed as a as a collective group that
we're not going to mix bleach with
anything we might dilute it with water
only but we're not going to mix it with
anything we're certainly not going to
mix it with toilet bowl cleaner one of
the things that we have to be painfully
aware of and this goes back to the ph
scale again 7 is neutral all the way
over to the side the zero are the acids
and all the way over the other side we
have 14 which are the alkalines when you
mix a product like clorox this is a
number 12 and a half and you mix it with
something all the way over to the other
scale that's an acid and it does
clorox does react to acids and so what
happens is you are creating toxic
cis situations where either the fumes
are going to be so strong they'll knock
you out and i promise you this there are
people that are hospitalized every day
for making stupid things like that and i
say stupid because they're really really
really stupid decisions please do not
mix chemicals do not mix it with toilet
bowl cleaner toilet bowl cleaner is a
one or a two on the complete opposite
end of the scale and while you think it
might cancel each other out because it
neutralizes
you know acids to alkaline the mixtures
are so toxic they can be fatal and so if
if i could implement or impart one piece
of wisdom do not mix anything with
bleach bleach bleach is very very
powerful all on its own it doesn't need
anything else the only thing it needs is
extreme caution
got it
okay cool all right do you guys have any
other questions uh if not i'm gonna let
you guys get back to your day i loved
spending my saturday morning with you
and we're gonna do this again next week
so that we can cover new tools and and
answer some of your questions there so
if you have any questions now is the
time to ask them
jump in here tell me what you have to
say
uh
violet so excellent says people today
think you can just use bleach for
everything oh i already read this one
this was awesome yes it's true and no
you can't please don't
uh denise said i think spring bleach in
the air was to fake people out into
thinking it was cleaned at all
a lot of people do that they'll spray
stuff with a strong chemical smell and i
want you to be careful please be careful
with chemicals if you're in the house
cleaning industry as long as i have been
20 30 years
your body
has chemical sensitivities and you have
to be really painfully aware that
there's only one version of us so please
protect your lungs please i know i know
for a couple of years it's been really
unpopular to wear a mask and there have
been people that have been really
polarizing on both sides of it like you
know
we've been wearing masks for 30 years
and this was long before the pandemic if
you're using strong chemicals please
wear your masks it has nothing to do
with a pandemic and everything to do
with your lungs protect yourself and if
you're going to use
like a really strong fume like for an
oven cleaner for example which is on
that side of the uh the ph scale really
close to the top and super strong you're
going to need an ozone generator for
that room when you leave you don't want
the family coming home smelling a whole
house full of fumes that are going to
affect their lungs
right like let's protect each other
let's take care of ourselves and let's
protect each other
all right that's it for today i'll let
you guys get back to your saturday
thanks again so much for joining me i've
really really enjoyed our time together
and like i said we'll do this again next
week
all right with that um
that's it see you soon
you